en quoi consistait votre célèbre régime
du camp à l'époque j'ai failli faire
écouter c'était un régime qui disait que
le sucre et les glucides rapides étaient
dangereux que les graisses étaient
beaucoup moins alors que à l'époque tout
le monde disait les Grèce et les
graisses qui se calories voilà et moi
j'avais que j'étais très jeune médecin
et
pendant les trois ans pendant les trois
ans oui très jeune pendant les 3 ans
c'est gentil pendant les trois ans de ma
spécialité j'avais pas beaucoup de sous
je revenais d'Algérie et je me suis dit
je vais m'installer en médecine générale
j'avais beaucoup de monde en médecine
générale donc un éditeur chez Seghers
une édition de poésie j'ai adoré ce mec
on parlait le directeur puis un jour il
me dit écoutez quand même mais c'est du
quand je vous aime beaucoup ouais bien
soigner pour les tas de choses mais je
suis obèse
j'ai dit j'avais oublié il me dit
maintenant il va falloir que vous
m'aidiez à maigrir et je dis mais j'y
connais rien moi de je m'occupe de de
neurologie je m'occupe pas du tout mais
si allez j'habite à côté de chez vous je
viens je me pèse on discute je dis non
je vais vous dire vous m'enlevez tout ce
que vous voulez sauf la viande
et comme je n'arrivais pas à me
avant de sortir j'ai dit ben écoutez
manger de la viande pendant 5 jours
buvez beaucoup d'eau et revenez me voir
il revient au bout de cinq jours il me
dit il avait perdu 140
kg et il me dit je crois que ma bascule
ne marche pas très bien je me pèse chez
moi
je me suis écouté c'est pas possible
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
et qu'est-ce que je fais je continue il
revient au bout de 5 jours 3 kg de bon
ça faisait 8 en 10 jours il m'a dit
écoutez je vous savez ce qui m'arrive je
peux me gratter le dos
il arrivait pas à se gratter le dos
tellement il était des bons et il me dit
je commence à l'avoir oui c'était vous
annoncer ça comme ça j'ai une nouvelle
incroyable je peux me gratter le dos
alors j'ai dit avoir quoi
il me dit que je me penche vous pouvez
pas savoir le plaisir que c'est pas de
problème monsieur je vois plus mes pieds
la troisième jambe
donc voilà ça a commencé comme ça et
après si vous voulez j'ai beaucoup axé
sur les protéines parce que les
protéines si vous laissez l'aliment de
l'homme primitif on a vécu 200000 ans
avec de la viande et et des feuilles et
de la salade et des racines et des
petits c'est tout donc moi le régime
protéiné c'était régime protéiné
attention je disais protéines autant que
vous voulez d'accord légumes autant que
vous pouvez d'accord ça veut dire que
les légumes c'était le maître mot mais
les journalistes n'ont vu qu'une chose
la viande c'est ça du camp c'est la
viande mais non c'est pas du camp raser
la viande il y avait des légumes mais
pourquoi vous avez été autant décrié
alors attendez j'ai eu une période de
grâce fabuleuse
c'est vrai que tout le monde disait il y
avait un régime qui marche le régime du
coup c'était le régime numéro
de parler que de votre méthode
18 millions 18 millions en 30 pays 18
millions euh magnifique
qu'est-ce qu'il y a eu alors après après
une fois et je pense qu'il y a eu
énormément de jalousie d'habitude bien
sûr quand vous explosez c'est sûr que ça
fait chier tout le monde regardez nous
si on faisait 30000 téléspectateurs on
aurait beaucoup moins de critiques
forcément c'est sûr donc à mon avis vous
avez dû déranger un moment en plus vous
venez vous avez raconté votre histoire
donc forcément vous étiez généraliste à
la base tout ça donc à mon avis il y en
a plein qui ont dû dire vous tombez
dessus et vous avez votre question j'ai
tenté à peu près tous les régimes parce
que j'avais une maigri je t'ai fait
toujours au dernier moment juste avant
l'été et c'est pas du tout pour faire la
pub parce que monsieur n'a plus besoin
c'est un autre régime maintenant mais
c'est un régime qui est parfait je
trouve pour les hommes parce que c'est
un régime on maigri tout de suite et on
a besoin de résultats tout de suite dès
le premier soir on voit que sur la
balance on maigri et surtout on peut
manger autant qu'on veut si on mange des
bons éléments alors que les autres
régimes on a l'impression d'être à
l'hôpital le manger quelques trucs et on
a toujours faim alors que là on a faim
on se lève hop on mange du poulet de la
dinde enfin des produits autorités etc
et ça c'est génial quand tu es un homme
c'est-à-dire tu peux bouffer après donc
ça marche pas tu reprends ok
ça ne fonctionne pas bien sûr ça
fonctionne mais
c'est normal si tu si tu fais un régime
et qu'après tu l'arrêtes et que tu
démontes bah forcément
tu veux quand même la volonté
il y a une étude qui a été faite par la
Salpêtrière qui était pas mes potes
c'est parce que Salpêtrière c'est le
milieu etc moi je suis pas dans la dans
dans à l'hôpital donc ils ont vu que ils
ont fait une enquête sur
4500 personnes qui avaient maigri avec
mon régime et ils ont dit qu'est-ce que
vous êtes devenu après le régime c'est
la question que vous avez posé 20% des
gens ont gardé leur poids au bout de 5
ans 20% bon et 80% ont repris voilà bon
c'est comme ça dans tous les rimes
c'était quoi le problème pourquoi il est
monté mauvais pour la santé mais jamais
personne n'a jamais dit que c'était moi
l'histoire vocaux non oui il y a eu des
gens qui ont dit les reins mais c'est
pas vrai ils études sont clairs pour les
reins il y a pas de problème donc les
protéines parce que quand même quand on
prend de la protéine en poudre comme ça
il y avait une légende qui disait que
c'était mauvais pour les reins est-ce
que c'est pas non c'est pas vrai non
vraiment donc je c'est pas vrai du tout
je vous envoie les toutes les études
américaines qui ont été faites là-dessus
il y a pas de problème c'est pas monté
il y a j'ai vu dans les analyses il y a
un truc qui montre quand on fait une
protéines
quand on a de retourner mais c'est
normal le rein de travail on a deux
reins moi j'ai 60 personnes que j'ai
fait maigrir que j'ai aidé à maigrir
parce que maigrir et qui n'avait qu'un
rein alors évidemment je l'ai surveillé
etc mais il y a pas trop là ils ont
jamais eu de problème de ce côté-là un
rein un seul rein vaut mieux que de
diluation aucune communication à faire
ce régime
la grossesse la grossesse l'allaitement
les maladies rénales bien sûr si vous
avez un problème de rein il faut pas
faire
on n'est pas des carences
des calculs mais ça
il y a 80 000 personnes en France qui
feront le calcul chaque année c'est le
favorise ou bien c'est
à dire que si vous avez une tendance à
faire des calculs manger beaucoup de
produits il faut boire de litres voilà
si vous buvez de litre tout s'élimine
d'accord si vous buvez un demi litre ça
concentre d'accord donc il faut boire
beaucoup il faut boire beaucoup
mais vous savez il y a énormément de
gens qui l'ont fait est-ce qu'il y a
quelqu'un qui est venu me dire j'ai eu
une maladie ou je suis mort je sais pas
enfin le truc par contre
un mec qui vient de tenir fort
tous les jours il y a des gens qui
meurent parce qu'ils sont trop gros
diabétiques alors tous les jours il y a
quelqu'un qui a dit par exemple il y a
plein de médecins spécialistes qui vous
sont tombés dessus et c'est normal quand
on marche bien forcément ça fait chier
tout le monde on reçoit aujourd'hui dans
le cabinet une quantité de passion qui
ont fait ce régime et on a une sorte de
désastre sanitaire c'est un des régimes
qui provoquent le plus l'effet yoyo on
parle de destruction du trouble de
comportement alimentaire parce que ces
passions ne savent plus savoir
à quel moment ils sont rassasiés
psychologiquement ces gens vont très mal
bon encore voilà ça c'est aussi c'est
c'est ils en font pas un petit bébé si
ces armatisfait de leur faire et c'est
lui aussi qu'est-ce qu'il vient de faire
dans nutrition un psy si vous voulez
alors il vous dit il vous dit il y a des
gens qui ont des anorexie ou de la
polymie d'accord c'est leur métier qui
traite c'est les maladies psychiatriques
mais une problème de poids c'est pas
leur métier aujourd'hui d'ailleurs c'est
un drame de voir sur internet le nombre
de de nutritionnistes auto déclaré qui
disent moi je suis maître nageur mais je
m'y connais autant que vous monsieur etc
et même mieux parce que je sais que
quand on nage il faut il faut nager la
bouche fermée sinon on avale de l'eau et
que la roue de l'Australie c'est pas bon
pour la tension mais vous entendez
sur l'ancien fournisseur sont retournés
contre vous certains vous reproches de
ne pas avoir été payés des salariés ont
été plusieurs à se plaindre dans un
rapport un salarié sur 13 présente des
symptômes liés au stress sur une année
d'écoute de l'organisation du travail
des relations éternelles internes
constituelles donc ça d'abord c'est pas
chez moi moi je suis dans une société
j'ai 17 % de départ c'est pas moi qui
dirige mais c'est vrai que bon ben dans
les sociétés il y a toujours des gens
qui sont nécessaires après il y a des
mecs qui disent voilà que c'est un voilà
de prendre n'importe qui n'importe qui
peut dire ça aussi de nous aussi donc
voilà bon après voilà oui mais c'est de
la jalousie et moi ce que j'aime bien
que le docteur Dukan c'est qui se met à
la place des personnes qui sont en
surpoids parce qu'aujourd'hui quand vous
avez 10 20 30 kilos à perdre vous allez
voir un nutritionniste en France hein je
parle il vous dit voilà faut manger du
pain du beurre de la confiture du
fromage etc il vous dit vous allez
perdre 100 g par semaine ou 100 g par
mois mais quand vous avez 30 kilos à
perdre vous êtes au bout de votre vie
parce que j'aime bien dans votre régime
c'est que il est efficace il va vite et
surtout vous compris que la notion de
modération sur certains produits comme
le sucre elle est pas la même pour tout
le monde il y a des gens qui ont pas de
problème avec l'alimentation il y a
d'autres gens qui ont des gros problèmes
et qui ne peuvent pas se contrôler quand
ils mangent du sucre donc moi j'aime
bien le côté entre guillemets dans le
bon sens du terme militaire de votre
régime parce qu'il permet aux gens de se
prendre en main et psychologiquement ça
va mieux mais je trouve qu'on a été très
dur avec lui et il y a plein de régime
qui provoque des carences
aussi du Médiator en 2011 vous aviez été
assignole dans l'affaire du Médiator
vous avez refusé de communiquer le
dossier médical d'une de vos patientes à
laquelle vous presquiviriez prescriviez
le Médiator comme coupe-faim il y a
développé une valvue l'autre partie
modérée chez cette dernière modérée mais
tous les médecins de France
prescrivaient du médiateur j'étais un
médicament anti diabète et diabète et
surpoids c'est quasiment la même chose
alors vous aviez été interdit d'exercer
la médecine pendant 8 jours
non non moi j'ai fini la médecine en
on va vous donner une parler de notre
nouveau régime dans un instant mais le
régime Dukan aurait été suivi par des
grandes personnalités il y a François
Hollande qui l'a suivi
mais après mais les mecs j'adore cette
histoire le but d'un régime parce que il
y a rien de plus dangereux que le yoyo
justement
[Musique]
au bout de trois mois tu manges que des
gâteaux et que tu prends des pizzas
toute la journée forcément tu vas me
demander au docteur c'est beaucoup mieux
d'avoir toute sa vie 10 kg en trop toute
sa vie toque de faire moins 20 + 10 + 20
les mecs qui viennent te voir il dit je
veux maigrir tu lui donnes une recette
pour maigrir si le mec après il a pas de
monter et qui va reprendre 25 kilos
qu'est-ce que tu veux faire tu es pas tu
vas pas le suivre toute la journée le
problème si vous voulez d'abord pour
répondre à votre question monsieur qui
est légitime il faut mettre le docteur
non ah oui je suis docteur
demander au docteur monsieur
[Musique]
vous êtes autorables
mais tous les médecins français quand
ils arrivent à l'âge de la retraite
demande leur radiation pour ne pas payer
les droits du conseil de ces 300 euros
par mois mais il y a des gens qui disent
NON je demande ma radiation
je voulais répondre à Madame 10 kg je
compare le surpoids et le tabac quand
une personne s'arrête de fumer en
principe qu'une personne s'arrête au
bout de cette fois c'est la moyenne hein
il y a des gens c'est plus d'autres
témoins quand vous vous arrêtez un an et
que vous reprenez pendant un an
vous avez des gazé vos poumons
légèrement pas totalement mais
pour quand vous avez perdu 20 Kilos même
si vous les reprenez vous les reprenez
pas tout de suite vous les reprenez par
petits morceaux mais pendant c'est
pendant une année vous avez vécu avec 20
kg de moins donc vous avez allégé votre
cholestérol vous avez alléger votre
santé vous avez un léger votre
hypertension bon je dis pas que c'est
bien qu'il faut mais c'est mieux que
rien c'est mieux que de rester avec 20
kg en plus sous le temps il y a Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui a fait exactement
il y a non mais il y avait il y a marine
Le Pen aussi exactement
vous savez
moi c'était pas ma patiente mais mais
j'ai vu dans les journaux qu'elle
prenait Jennifer Lopez
[Musique]
[Rires]
surtout Kate Middleton je sais la future
reine d'Angleterre mais je sais je la
connais grave mais elle a poussé loin
quand même ouais
elle était trop moche hein